ça a pété dans la rue et voilà que j'ai
vu mourir devant mes yeux bat aller au
atterrir sur le sol et le feu venir sur
moi et j'ai vu une boule de soirée
besson je n'ai pas perdu connaissance et
j'ai tout vu de toute la scène donc tous
les jours j'ai 16 images là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous ex candidate de télé-réalité
23 ans un million de followers sur
instinct mois plus à deux reprises dans
deux émissions différentes donc l'avant
dernière et la dernière donc pas les
princes de l'amour quand j'ai eu mes
prétendants dont on m'a demandé
d'accélérer le pas avec un de mes
prétendants de l'embrasser et des choses
comme ça dans ma dana mission donc
objectif reste du monde la production à
plusieurs reprises m'a dit rapproche toi
d'ailleurs à l'époque c'était ilan gens
proches ou dylan on aimerait que tu te
rapproches dylan et c'est moi ilan
physiquement c'était pas mon style et
voilà je très gentil mais voilà sans
plus et en fait j'ai appris par la suite
quand j'ai été éliminé au premier tour
que c'était à cause de ça parce que je
ne voulais pas faire d'histoires il ya
ceux qui candidatent de télé réalité m'a
dit la semaine dernière elle m'a raconté
qu'elle était sur une émission je peux
pas donner le nom elle était sur une
émission la productrice lui avait dit si
tu ne couche pas les termes exacts un
signe il ne couche pas on te met à
l'écart et honteux virtu ne refera plus
d'émissions avec vous donc là ça
s'apparente à des pressions qui sont ce
que tu as tu reçu des menaces et des
pressions par écrit c'est pas des
menaces mais c'est de la pression c'est
par exemple ce genre de choses où tu
dois faire des histoires tu dois faire
des soirées garçon tu dois t'en brouille
avec certaines personnes parce que sinon
tu n'es pas vu à la télé donc à qu'est
ce que tu fais en télé si tu ne cites on
ne te voit pas c'est cdc dépression
comme ça en fait c'est plutôt la télé y
a rien de méchant c'est si vous arrivez
vous êtes un petit peu calme ou l'ehpad
amourette voulais pas montrer autre
chose bah pardon mais dans ces cas là
pour nous vous dire mais faut pas forme
avoir la télévision a ouvert une
mystique alors moi personnellement
c'était pas mon cas je pense que plus 20
j'ai quand même du caractère j'ai jamais
eu de problème à faire des histoires
avec des garçons qui me plaisait bien au
contraire j'ai eu même des histoires par
la suite à cause de ces garçons là où on
a exposé ma vie intime en télé et je
trouve ça n'est pas normal qu'on ne
recherche pas assez le passif des
candidats avant de les faire rentrer en
télé moi mon prétendants il a été accusé
six mois plus tard avant après avoir été
en prétendant de violences conjugales
j'ai notifié trois fois à la production
je vais virer moi même six mois plus
tard il a été accusé de violence
conjugale donc déjà il ya un gros
problème sur les recherches en amont sur
les candidats deuxième chose le suivi
psychologique il y à 0 suivi
psychologique s'il ya des productions
qui ont aussi ça je précise dans ma
deuxième télé une production qui faisait
des bandes sons qui coupait des mots qui
prenait d'autres sosies tv de moi et qui
me faisait des phrases que je n'avais
jamais dit de ma vie qui détruisait mon
image qui détruisait mon image c'est
pour moi c'est un système qui est ultra
malsain
[Musique]
examen du corps en entier au scanner
confirme qu'il ya un petit cancer du
poumon est donc ça c'était au mois de
mai
alors ça c'est dans le documentaire qui
passera le 9 décembre
nathalie donc comment tu as appris ce se
faisant cuire nous le nom de nous
l'expliquent tels que jean-pierre quand
il a passé tous ses examens non c'est
moi j'ai juste poussé parce qu'il avait
une bronchite sans arrêt donc c'est
normal on est tous et beaucoup donc j ce
serait peut-être temps que tu ailles
faire de nouveau des examens et puis
donc il a fait un premier examen et puis
il disait il ya quelque chose qui est
pas très près clair et puis comme il
raconte il a fait un scanner lamont le
verdict est tombé et donc ça s'est passé
au mois de juillet on a fait on est
passé trois semaines à l'hôpital et
s'est fait opérer tout s'est très bien
passé et puis ben là au mois de
septembre ça attaque et l'autre tout le
monde donc par contre c'était un peu
plus chiant parce que
c'était un peu plus gros et
donc là c'est clair qu'on peut passer
par une opération parce que ça c'est
beaucoup trop lourd donc là il est fait
de la radiothérapie
et puis puis la moral d'acier et puis on
est au près de lui toute sa famille et
puis et puis se bat et puis comme on dit
jamais deux sans trois on a fait un
chacun un cancer et puis ma y en a un
autre qui vient qui le mot cancer ça
veut pas dire la mort automatiquement
s'il avait annoncé qu aux enfants
comment tous les w non c'est surtout moi
c'est surtout moi j'ai oui j'ai toujours
l'habitude de parler avec mes enfants
comme pour le cancer de la prostate j'ai
toujours prévenu mes enfants parce que
j'ai pas envie de leur mentir il dit
soit les médecins pour l'instant on peut
rien dire encore parce que l'on donc
fait la radiothérapie et au mois de
janvier ont grimpé scan pour voir où ça
en est et là seulement on prend
ça évolue quand on se complaît pas
savoir tout de suite là je suis venu ce
soir c'est parce que bah ça s'ébruite en
ce moment je sais donc c'est pour ça que
je suis venu là ce soir sinon on avait
le reportage on l'avait bien préparé
avec jean-pierre ça devait pas se dire
ce soir j'avais vous vouliez pas en
parler sinon c'est ça c'est parce que
vous avez vu que ça s'ébruite et où j'ai
dit oui parce que jean-pierre pouvait
pas venir ce soir donc il m'a dit baba
zinat parce que bien sûr dans les
réseaux oui elle vient pour pour faire
parler d'elle voilà les gens sans les
nommer c'est important que vous dire
pouvait pas venir ce soir et que vous
vouliez que ça comme l a vu que ça
brille c'est sur les réseaux vous a dit
je préfère expliquer moi ce qui se passe
et on en est plutôt que de voir tout
n'importe quoi exactement vous avez peur
aujourd'hui nathalie
si je vous dis non ça serait immense
assurances et ça serait un mensonge bien
évidemment que j'ai peur mais
on fait confiance aux médecins
karim benzema je dis que j'aime voilà je
laime karim il le sait quand je dis moi
qui est un ami on est là avec nous tous
les moments réduit et il a été condamné
à un an de prison avec sursis dans la
sphère de la sextape le joueur du real
madrid et de l'équipe de france était
poursuivi pour complicité de chantage
sur mathieu valbuena son ancien
coéquipier en équipe de france je
remercie d'être en tout cas m karim
benzema a donc été reconnu coupable
ce que vous comprenez ce verdict
forcément non non parce qu'il est
factuellement déjà erronée selon nous il
condamne karim benzema pour des faits
qui ne se sont pas produits en fait la
conversation alléguée entre karim
benzema et valbuena personne ne la
connaît y'a pas de tout à l'heure vous
avez parlé de la bouteille d'eau on a la
vidéo la ja pas la vidéo il ya pas les
enregistrements et on essaie de l'art
tissé à partir d'une autre conversation
que karim a eu avec un de ses amis et
moi je trouve que c'est très dangereux
d' essayer d'interpréter des
conversations on sélectionne un mot on
en enlève un autre dans cette
conversation par exemple karim benzema
10 à la fin que mathieu valbuena l'a
remercié c'est un peu étrange de dire
que quelqu'un qui aurait sur lui fait
des pressions lors est remercié donc on
espérait vraiment que au regard de ces
arguments là et du fait que c'est une
histoire quand même qui est très
ancienne aujourd'hui la condamnation de
monsieur benzema et l'autre elle est
lourde d'ailleurs le procureur avait il
faut pas le juger comme tout va la
baisser au maximum s'il est condamné à
deux ans d'emprisonnement avec sursis
75000 euros d'amendé malheureusement le
jugement il est erroné disproportionnée
il donne raison à cet argument qui avait
été de 10 dans le réquisitoire qui est
qu' il doit pas être jugé comme tout le
monde parce que c'est benzema et nous ça
nous choque d'entendre ça et lui ça le
choc dans le temps de ça il n'est pas un
justiciable ou au dessus mais pas non
plus au dessous des lois et donc à
partir de là il va faire appel et il
viendra s'expliquer parce qu'il a eu
toujours à coeur de le faire on a lu
qu'en fait il s'était pas présenté à son
procès c'est sûr qu'au 10 ans et un
procès entre un match de la ligue et
bien sûr l'épopée le le madrid barcelone
pour un sportif de haut niveau il avait
deux choix soit il demandait à ce qu'on
leur pouce il n'a pas choisi cette
option là soit il disait au tribunal
qu'ils n'étaient pas là si le tribunal
avait voulu le faire venir il l'aurait
fait ils ont accepté de le juger sur le
dossier peut-être que ce n'était pas la
bonne chose à faire en tout cas on
appelle il viendra s'expliquer et il
viendra redire ce qu'il a toujours dit
il n'est jamais intervenu dans le cadre
d'une infraction pénale qui est quand
même quelque chose bien défini il
faudrait qu'il ait menacé valbuena et
lui dire que s'il ne satisfait pas à ccc
demande la vidéo va sortir sait
absolument pas ce qui s'est passé et
c'est absolument pas même dans la pire
interprétation ce qui ressortirait la
discussion la seule à partir de laquelle
tout le monde at on glose et
merci à océane et inès d'être venu nous
voir ça fait longtemps qu'on veut avoir
votre témoignage parce que c'est une
histoire complètement folle on se
rappelle tous 1,2
de cette explosion qui a eu à paris dans
le 9ème arrondissement rue de trévise et
on hallucine de savoir que près de trois
ans après rien ne s'est passé pour vous
c'était ce 12 janvier 2019 finesse vous
vous rendez pour la troisième fois à
votre nouveau travail rue de trévise
vous arrivez vous voyez déjà un camion
de pompiers vous sentez l'odeur des gars
de gaz déjà déjà un camion de pompiers
avant avant avant que l'explosion
c'était en plein week-end de julia de
chez les jeunes donc je pensais que la
police et les pompiers étaient justement
là par rapport aux jeunes qu'ils
allaient traverser le grand boulevard
donc on ne prête pas attention au fait
qu' un camion de pompiers sur ce
7 heures du matin
ça vous a pas du tout inquiétés pour la
la donc peu avant 9 heures vous
ressortez vous voyez le pompier s'agiter
on est à quelques secondes avant le
drame exactement on est à 10 minutes
alors un 10 minutes je sors je vois les
pompiers qui cherche quelque chose il ne
trouve pas il fait avec mes deux
collègues et on s'apprête à rentrer dans
l'hôtel et puis j'en entends un qui dit
fête ça y est je les trouvais et donc je
me retourne pour voir il y en a un des
deux son compagnon qui prend une clé
pour justement fermer le tuyau de gaz et
l'explosion bas je pense qu'il a pas
réussi à faire mieux tuyaux parce que ça
a pété dans la rue et voilà lots que
j'ai vu mourir devant mes yeux baal et
en os atterrir sur le sol et le feu
venir sur moi et
j'avais une boule de son arrivée son
ouais je n'ai pas perdu connaissance et
j'ai tout vu de toute la scène donc tous
les jours j'ai ces images là et donc en
fait le brouillard par la fumée par et
je vois que j'ai plus de jambes au
dessus j'ai commencé colette j'ai plus
les objets plus les muscles que j'ai
plus rien il me restait que la peau en
bas et plus le brouillard par puis je
découvre que mon pied est bloqué sous
une porte et bah j'ai plus rien ma jambe
gauche y avait plus rien mon tibia droit
y avait plus rien du tout j'étais en
sous-vêtements à 6 à crier à l'aide et
personne n'était là enfin il y avait des
clients de l'hôtel qui me marcher dessus
avec leur valise et qui partent et enfin
me regarder et j'étais désespéré je leur
demandais d'appeler les pompiers mais
par peur ils sont tous enfuis
donc je peux encore pendant 45 minutes
j'étais assise par terre à le vider de
son sens et à me dire bah quand est-ce
qu'on allait me trouver
j'ai suivi plus de 40 opérations 41 et
la janvier je retourne par la 42e vous
disais que vous ne pourriez plus marcher
on m'a dit oui les trois premiers mois
on m'a dit que c'était fauteuil roulant
avis que baye avait plus d'espoir quand
mes jambes que c'était fini voilà qu'ils
avaient pratiquement tout fait mais
c'était impossible qu'on dise que je
remarche avait plus personne ne peut
décider à ma place donc c'est pas
possible cette battue je me suis battu
ça a été dur même niveau des
indemnisations il avait reçu aucune
indemnisation de la mairie de paris qui
est mise en examen ou du syndic de
copropriété aussi qu'ils n'ont personne
n'a voulu nous verser quoi que ce soit
et ce qui est sûr la structure dans
cette histoire c'est que l ai fait
croire qu'il lui fallait une loi pour
indemniser des victimes qui le maire de
paris la maire de paris dont elle a
écrit un courrier à jean castex il ya un
an pour demander une loi etc en fait
elle a fait perdre du temps alors que
plusieurs fois elle a débloqué des fonds
ne sont jamais avoir demandé l'avis du
gouvernement et nous comme par hasard
alors qu'on ait des victimes de qu'on a
besoin de ça pour nos soins de prise en
charge les psychologues etc rien océane
merci d'être là vous ce jour de janvier
vous avez perdu votre compagnon
nathanaël un des deux pompiers morts
dans l'explosion
au départ en plus il part c'était censé
être une opération tout à fait basique
basique non parce qu'elle est fine de
gamme est tombé bas les enfants souvent
moi c'est ça bon c'est pas qu'il allait
mourir ce jour-là à qu'ils allaient
mourir ce jour là alors dit je suis là
pour bamako zh pour lui mais surtout
pour son petit garçon de six ans
qui regardent actuellement quand il ça
peut être quelqu'un qui lit mon
passeport et qui est tellement fier ton
papa c'est son super héros il peut ils
étaient tellement proches et sont ils se
ressemblent énormément ça fait bizarre
mais on connaît les risques en tant que
femme en tant que parent on de pompiers
de paris
mais on s'attend pas
excusez moi mais aucun problème à les
perdre pour de la négligence j'ai allumé
la télé mon père qui avait pour habitude
de regarder bfm mme à la première chaîne
qui s'affichait bfm et en fait j'ai
appris par bfm l'explosion en
connaissant un peu le secteur de nos
compagnes nous et à chaque achat qu on
essaye de garder les deux mains toujours
le poste qu'il a donc conducteur ce jour
là je me suis dit tout de suite et je
sais pas pourquoi je n'ai ressenti au
plus profond de moi je me suis dit m yep
et j'ai pris cette décision d'appeler la
caserne qui est quand même une enceinte
militaire donc on ne prend pas une
décision comme ça à la légère surtout
qu'il a toujours demandé pas le faire ce
qui est normal et là je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai dit il faut que je le
fasse et effectivement heureusement que
je les fais parce que umar je tombais
sur quelqu'un tout de suite si mac et
s'il me réconforter comme vous pouvait
on trouver pas nathanel effectivement
idier terme on savait pas où il était et
puis à deuxième m'appelle pour me dire
que nathanaël et dans l'hélicoptère qui
les transportait à l'hôpital militaire
de béja
et puis hein et puis quelques minutes
après je passe le téléphone à babel mère
parce qu impossible pour moi de nous
dire que là on va me dire je sais ce
qu'on va me dire je le sais ils en
avaient cardio respiratoire il a été
soufflé il a été retrouvé encastré sous
cette voiture
et nous on m'a dit c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]